TO THE APRIL TWENTY SIX HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO STARTED LIKE TO
THANK THE STAFF THAT MADE
POSSIBLE OUR ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STATE PARTICIPATION IN OUR
HEARINGS. TO THAT END ALL NOW
SHARE A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS OF OUR HEARING TODAY
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
TO HELP PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE TODAY AND TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE
CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
AND FACE COVERING REQUIREMENTS
FOR EVERYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
BILL. BUILDING ONLY ABL TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATING HEARING
IN PERSON WITH A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. I WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
DIALING WITNESSES THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON
ITSELF- HOWEVER. YEAH THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO NOW NOW.
THE OPERATOR LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACING QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE ABOUT.
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST YOUR SMART. DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
ABOUT DISRUPTIONS. I WOULD LIKE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ASSEMBLY
COUNTER REPEATED DISRUPTIONS OF
ITS PRECEDING THREE YEARS AND
THESE. HAVE INCREASED THIS
YEAR. RECENT DISRUPTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT PROCEEDING TURN
ASSEMBLY AND THE U. S. CAPITOL
NECESSITATE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS. AND RULES
AGAINST DISRUPTION CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING IS PROHIBITED. IF
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR
CHRISTADELPHIAN BE REMOVED. BY
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS OR
YOU'LL BE REMOVED FROM THE.
CALL. THIRTEEN LET'S SEE I
BELIEVE. WE HAVE ENOUGH FOR A
QUORUM. CALDERON I. YOUR ALL
RIGHT ARAMBULA. HERE. THANK YOU
SIR SAID WE HAVE ONE MEASURE ON
CONSENT IT'S AB ONE THREE FOR
FIVE BY. THANK YOU. OKAY- I DO
WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE. OPERATOR. YEAH.
IT'S A BILL SO WE DON'T NEED TO
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A FIRST. OKAY. OKAY WE
HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THERE'S ITS CONSENT
BILL. EXACTLY YEAH. ANYONE WORK
OKAY OPERATOR DO WE ANYONE ON
THE LINE SUPPORT. EVERY LYING
DIALED IN OVER THE AT THE TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON CONSENT CALDERON.
I CALDERON I DAVIS DAVIS I
ARAMBULA. CHOI CHU I'D GIPSON
GIVES A ICE STAR AYE- THAT WILL
PUT OUT I WORE WARD HI. THE
VOTER SEVENTY ZERO THANK YOU.
SAVE A LEAVES ROLE OF FOR FIVE
MINUTES OKAY. THE BILL THIS ONE
BILL THANK YOU MANAGER. I LIKE
THE YEAH. THAT. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR KERN VOTE SEVEN ZERO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HIGH FINAL
VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO. THANK YOU
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED. I
REMEMBER. BUT I THINK I'M IT UP
NO. THANK YOU. YEAH THANK.